**Susan Daniels***: Welcome back everyone.
**Susan Daniels***: I see a lot of people got their names confirmed and on you stay logged on so great.
**Susan Daniels***: The system should not have logs you out on break it may just been a spike in your local area for those of the person who are logged out unexpectedly um.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay volume is not working let's.
**Susan Daniels***: let's look into that my mute is on me, he is on i'm sharing.
**Susan Daniels***: haha I think everyone's muted.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, you can hear me now great Thank you um so you should not have been logged out by the system on break the system was operational so staying logged on should have been the goal and should have been successful for you um I did see a great idea coming through the chat when we were.
**Susan Daniels***: On break it was about creating and joining study groups, and I think that is a great idea if anyone wants to create one maybe a few their linkedin page send out their linkedin.
**Susan Daniels***: and say hey join me for a study group here or send out a contact through the chat for people to join a study group for you, you may want to do it by.
**Susan Daniels***: North America, Europe basically timezone Asia, so that your meeting hours would be consistently agreeable so.
**Susan Daniels***: I encourage you all to take the initiative to start to create study groups among yourselves they've been organized by state, because people who actually wanted to try to get together and study.
**Susan Daniels***: By town in whatever way you want to launch it is a great strategy to keep people motivated and to keep you accountable for your goal.
**Susan Daniels***: If you miss a week people reach out and go hey you know you still you still going for this and if you're supposed to have studied at a certain point.
**Susan Daniels***: In the materials, you know, having somebody accountable, you know expecting you to be there and ready to study with you can keep you moving down that path to success, so I.
**Susan Daniels***: Really recommend using your chat as a benefit of being part of such a large cohort to augment your experience, so I look forward to seeing um study groups begin to arise.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay i've got a hand raised on.
**Susan Daniels***: See.
**Susan Daniels***: Right, remember, to use your attendance tracker that um if you have to log off for any reason, or if you accidentally had a power surge and we're on drop for a little while how long were you off and when were you able to get back on.
**Susan Daniels***: So this particular.
**Susan Daniels***: session we're still in session one, we are in the am we are doing the second part of the three parts this morning and we're still in build a team and we're also going to be covering.
**Susan Daniels***: Let me check that for just a moment we're also going to be covering define team ground rules so that's what we'll be covering for the next hour or so.
**Susan Daniels***: So.
**Susan Daniels***: One thing that we need to do is project leaders is to appraise the skill set that we have the team we've got not all of us are able to.
**Susan Daniels***: acquire our teams, sometimes we were just handed a team and for those of you in the military i'm sure you're very familiar with you work with who you have right so it's very important to assess our prize those team skills and.
**Susan Daniels***: it's not just what are they know but it's also what do they want to learn what do they want to grow and expand maybe they're tired they've kind of peaked at what they've done.
**Susan Daniels***: And now, they like to contribute in new ways and maybe they'd like to be mentored a job shadow, as well as doing what it is that they were brought on the team to do in the first place, so you really want to see what their team preferences are you want to go in and look at.
**Susan Daniels***: It may be able to grow and develop your on your players, so that you have a stronger set of resources, the next time you come to that that division, for their support.
**Susan Daniels***: So what kind of tools do we use.
**Susan Daniels***: Well, there was a variety of team assignment tools.
**Susan Daniels***: attitudinal surveys right um some people prefer to work with people, some people prefer ideas others prefer working with their hands really understanding how they want to.
**Susan Daniels***: To engage, you may want to look at.
**Susan Daniels***: Do they have the right personality profile for the kind of work that you having them do some people are really very comfortable meeting strangers talking before others communicating ideas that they're.
**Susan Daniels***: Just barely familiar with, but you know they can wing it there they're just really.
**Susan Daniels***: Good gary's communicators and you ask them to do very detailed focus on work and they're not going to excel at it.
**Susan Daniels***: same if you take the accounting personality profile someone who's very good attention to detail may be scared down to their their toes having to do a public presentation about the project, so you need to understand your team's personality profiles their attitudes right.
**Susan Daniels***: We use on structured interviews, and this is becoming.
**Susan Daniels***: Very common today in the market, where you do pre screenings, particularly when you have the the benefit of like these large job boards.
**Susan Daniels***: And they just want to run you through a funnel of filters before you actually get to the hiring manager well.
**Susan Daniels***: As much as you can be on the receiving end of that you can also be on the giving end of that, and you can run your team through some.
**Susan Daniels***: filters are skill set tasks to see whether you think got what they need to be able to contribute to your project and if not, then, then all goes into your development plan, where are the gaps.
**Susan Daniels***: Now it's interesting that you might see focus groups when it's talking about trying to.
**Susan Daniels***: build your team a focus group is really where you bring some of the stakeholders together and you're trying to identify what you need in your team.
**Susan Daniels***: And they they help you you don't have to be the only person making the decision, they work with you to identify what would be the ideal candidate candidate and then they help you assess your.
**Susan Daniels***: Your options against that ideal so focus groups can be very helpful as well and building your team.
**Susan Daniels***: They also help you when i'm identifying vendor options.
**Susan Daniels***: So there is a variety of tools that we use to do team skill assessment, but one thing that we should be very sensitive to is diversity equity and inclusion.
**Susan Daniels***: No longer is it Okay, just to have people who look and sound exactly like you on your team, we have seen diversity and.
**Susan Daniels***: Inclusion rise strongly through the arm certainly here in North America and.
**Susan Daniels***: This is something that project managers should not just be sensitive to what should be leaders in.
**Susan Daniels***: We should understand that different perspectives provide different insights and you want as much insight as possible when you're trying to run a project.
**Susan Daniels***: People see the world from different ways, and they can help you risk identify and solution identify that you would not have thought of yourself so be very sensitive to trying to build a team that reflects the Community that you're in and its diversity.
**Susan Daniels***: There are whole training classes, on how to do i'm cultural sensitivity and how to build your own cultural competence, I strongly encourage you to to study these to be engaged in this aspect now how is this test it on the quest on the test, I mean, how is the question on the test i'm.
**Susan Daniels***: Really, one of the things is going to ask you are could ask you i'm not going to tell you what's on the test, because I don't know for a fact, but on what is the value proposition of.
**Susan Daniels***: Being inclusive in your team well one of us, it gives you a more collaborative culture It empowers the team, you want to arm and build more trust if.
**Susan Daniels***: If everyone is exactly the same there tend to be.
**Susan Daniels***: A dominant structure that develops rapidly, but if you have a diversified and you promote inclusiveness and everyone is respected and everyone's opinion is valued, then what you have is more of a lateral or a flat.
**Susan Daniels***: sort of hierarchy to your project team, and that makes everybody more comfortable contributing.
**Susan Daniels***: So you want to promote inclusiveness and not interrupting each other, showing respect for one another, I listening to everyone's opinion that's sort of hallmarks of how you implement this.
**Susan Daniels***: One moment okay so you've got your team and now what we're trying to build towards is to create a resource management plan.
**Susan Daniels***: The resource management plan is something you're going to come back to time and time again.
**Susan Daniels***: it's going to have not just cool you have and the roles that they're having their responsibilities, but you also need to have a way of organizing them.
**Susan Daniels***: And we go beyond that, in our resource management plan we start talking about training needs and what sort of tools and assets as assets they're going to need like what physical assets they're going to need.
**Susan Daniels***: So i'm going to pause a moment i'm going to talk about this before we jump into virtual teams, which is a type of team, you would build.
**Susan Daniels***: You will see key words here on the left is important if English is not your first language than to understand the difference between authority responsibility and competence, these are.
**Susan Daniels***: test question areas any vocabulary is definitely a a rich wealth from which questions can be pulled.
**Susan Daniels***: Many times, people are given the responsibility to get things done, but aren't given the authority in which to execute in which to get the resources they need to be successful.
**Susan Daniels***: So I think we've in our careers, many of us have experienced a lot of responsibility with insufficient authority and then we've also I suspect seen people who've taken a lot of authority and keep it to themselves, but won't take the responsibility.
**Susan Daniels***: there's an old saying that you can delegate authority to help people get the resources they need to be able to move forward to execute but, ultimately, the Leader remains responsible and that's true in project management, you will have.
**Susan Daniels***: A lot of responsibility and you have the ability to also delegate, not the responsibility for this whole project, but a lot of the authorities that you may have to help people be empowered to get the work done.
**Susan Daniels***: So be liberal and delegating your authority, if you think the person has the competence, yes competence is really having the skills to get the work done and today we're trying to build our competence in project management.
**Susan Daniels***: As we build our competence, we will build our responsibility and as we build our responsibility we we build our authority, these are all interwoven.
**Susan Daniels***: Why am I spending so much time on this, because this area is something that, as a project leader, you need to understand the difference between.
**Susan Daniels***: don't assume just because you've given someone their responsibility, they have a competence.
**Susan Daniels***: don't be don't assume just because they have the responsibility assigned to them, they have the all the authority, they need to be effective, you need to be sensitive as the project leader to the authority and competence to the people you've given the responsibility.
**Susan Daniels***: So Another thing I want to highlight off this slide is that you'll need a project organizational chart now your racy which we've already covered.
**Susan Daniels***: is one thing that you can use to help organize and understand task by task who's responsible accountable who's going to be informed and who's going to consult that an org chart is more.
**Susan Daniels***: How to cook reports to who Okay, what is the hierarchy Okay, are the organization, when you start a team it saves so much time in people, knowing where they fit into the big picture, so just have that ready, from the beginning.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay we'll talk about training strategies and requirements and a little bit, but that is part of your your resource plan, and this is often overlooked and it shouldn't be so this is very poorly spelled out on your slide how to reward and recognition blue.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay student question on slide 30 wouldn't these these pre assignment, let me.
**Susan Daniels***: i've got a question coming through.
**Susan Daniels***: On slide 33.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: When these pre assignment tools, be better served with human resource management, not necessarily through the individual projects proposal.
**Susan Daniels***: team building process bottom line is that for has to be paid for in both scheduling costs that impacts, the projects overall budget, I agree with you.
**Susan Daniels***: In raising the question, however, we are still in build the team so we're still trying to assess on the team that we have the potential candidates and the type of.
**Susan Daniels***: candidates that we want for the players that we have.
**Susan Daniels***: The building your team is often done in collaboration with HR so you're directionally correct, yes it is done with HR and many times.
**Susan Daniels***: They have to have the tools and resources, you need they often guide new project managers on how to do it well how to structure these pre assessments.
**Susan Daniels***: me so but it isn't done after the project is going Okay, so, if I understood the question correctly, it is in collaboration with hr.
**Susan Daniels***: But we are building the team and we're estimating we haven't fully at this point, got on to what our budget is or what to our schedule is hey we are we haven't gotten that far we're just looking at the resources that are required.
**Susan Daniels***: Much like who are stakeholders, what kind of team, do we need.
**Susan Daniels***: Building in Aris, a reward and recognition plan, many companies have these in place already.
**Susan Daniels***: You simply need to be well versed in it, but when you go to do your resource management plan, you should put money into your budget.
**Susan Daniels***: For reward and recognition, because if you don't the project manager odds are nobody else is going to so it's always worth the effort to ladder line for reward and recognition I typically added $500 or one half of a percent of the total personnel costs for my project.
**Susan Daniels***: Leadership often had trouble disputing the need to reward and recognize success and if all I asked for was a half a percent other personnel costs, I usually got it.
**Susan Daniels***: So we have worked with HR we have identified estimating what team we've needed we've talked about on.
**Susan Daniels***: The talent resources attitude skills that are required, now we need to talk about how is this team, going to be structured, is it going to be on ground is it going to be hybrid or is it going to be virtual.
**Susan Daniels***: Today, things are becoming more and more hybrid we all live through it being virtual for the most part and we've learned a lot of lessons about virtual teams and I think we're a lot better at them now quite honestly.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm.
**Susan Daniels***: What makes them virtual is that it's literally we're not co located Okay, and there are certain skills that are required and concerns associated with virtual teams.
**Susan Daniels***: here's the list of considerations.
**Susan Daniels***: i'll give you a moment to consume slide.
**Susan Daniels***: What the biggest advantage of using virtual teams is that we don't have to have the person.
**Susan Daniels***: Literally come into the building and we don't have to have a voice relocation costs, which means we now can have a talent pool from around the world right which is amazing.
**Susan Daniels***: we've talked about globalization now is here, we can apply for opportunities around the world if we're willing to stay up late or get up really early okay.
**Susan Daniels***: um but what are the biggest challenges is keeping them engaged okay i'm enabling effective team performance being able to.
**Susan Daniels***: share the same information concurrently and there's a lot of tools now monday.com project management COM.
**Susan Daniels***: Right assign you guys want to mention a couple of tools in the chat that you've been using to manage your projects and so that everyone on the virtual team can see the same information.
**Susan Daniels***: And access it the same way sharepoint sharing information through that click up right Hello.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, good tool stack teams a lot teams is becoming more and more popular slack slack is really risen in popularity as a team management tool, it was.
**Susan Daniels***: heavily used by students and now it's really become on industry i've been impressed by its rise box is a great place for storing on on the web, right in the cloud.
**Susan Daniels***: Google right.
**Susan Daniels***: Google is got his whole platform.
**Susan Daniels***: So, as you can see, there are a lot of tools out there that are helping project managers manage virtual teams.
**Susan Daniels***: But we've got to assign project responsibilities.
**Susan Daniels***: Well there's several things that we take into consideration for the most part we've touched a lot of this we recognize that.
**Susan Daniels***: it's not just the skill, they have do they have can they bring more to the table, or can they be more generalized and just their specific skill.
**Susan Daniels***: we've talked about and attitude or personality profile aligned to the kind of work and when you're talking about designing and building your team.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm self organizing teams agile uses self organizing teams, which means it has all the skills that I need ideally has all the skills that it needs in that team.
**Susan Daniels***: And they decide how they're going to allocate the work which is very different from traditional project management.
**Susan Daniels***: Where TEAM members are told what their accountabilities are, and then they go forth and execute will do more control comparing and contrasting of agile teams versus traditional teams when we get to day, five.
**Susan Daniels***: But please know there is a significant difference between agile team organization or assignment of responsibilities they decide among themselves, the work that they're going to work on in a sprint.
**Susan Daniels***: or in an iteration and they allocate that work among themselves and traditional very much year you stay to your role and you do the work that is tasked to you.
**Susan Daniels***: More on that to come, also referred to as traditional for your notes key word here is on cell phones organizing for agile i'm assigned Okay, for the work breakdown structure for traditional.
**Susan Daniels***: A major consideration for building your team is also rates right um are we going to be able to get top talent in the industry can we get the best.
**Susan Daniels***: Can we get the best in class are we willing to to pay that or do we need to be very conservative and maybe even try to get a pack of interns and have them work on it for a semester right, we need to take into account the cost of different.
**Susan Daniels***: options, and of course there's offsets for each one of those their skills, their experience their availability Okay, there are many considerations when building your team and that acquisitions we're still in that kind of all things, we take into consideration when acquiring our team.
**Susan Daniels***: So.
**Susan Daniels***: We have identified how we're going to structure our team we've identified what kind of rates that we can afford and what kind of talent, that we can get.
**Susan Daniels***: create a project management plan that includes this is just a summary slide and touched on this before.
**Susan Daniels***: who's your team and well how are they assigned what are their roles and responsibilities.
**Susan Daniels***: You can have your team directory, which is always helpful you do your your organizational structure.
**Susan Daniels***: And you do a team directory so that I don't have to try to find Sally Louise or Jen I can just go to this kept up to date.
**Susan Daniels***: team directory, this is often built by the project manager or someone that is good at these things and likes the attention to detail Okay, and is put out on the sharepoint site.
**Susan Daniels***: Very important to have your org charts How does everybody relate to everybody Okay, this is your project org chart, this is not the corporate org chart this is your projects or chart.
**Susan Daniels***: And then your resource assignment, this also has to do with the availability of equipment resources, it can be when do you have access to the conference rooms.
**Susan Daniels***: When do you have access to the testing environment okay certain are when do you have access to key equipment, so your project schedules will also have.
**Susan Daniels***: Your resources loaded on that.
**Susan Daniels***: Any questions at this point.
**Susan Daniels***: Who is.
**Susan Daniels***: OK, not saying any specific questions, unless you're typing i'll keep my eye open for it.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, and.
**Susan Daniels***: Now we need to talk about.
**Susan Daniels***: nurturing team performance it's your job as the project leader project manager okay to.
**Susan Daniels***: to oversee monitor and control team performance but you don't want to come across as a super supervisor Okay, you want to come across as someone who's enabling and empowering okay.
**Susan Daniels***: And one of the things that we do is that we make sure our staff have access to the information that they need when they need it right.
**Susan Daniels***: um.
**Susan Daniels***: And you talk to you by using those different pre assessment tools that we talked about to find out where the gaps are right.
**Susan Daniels***: And if there are gaps, can you fill it from within your team already maybe somebody already knows how to do it just nobody asked them if they knew how to do it it's always worth asking.
**Susan Daniels***: See, if anyone wants to volunteer who can mentor somebody else on how to do it.
**Susan Daniels***: But you're also develop responsible for developing the training plan, if there are gaps.
**Susan Daniels***: project managers are wholly accountable for their team to build them to organize them to.
**Susan Daniels***: set their direction and to empower them with the knowledge, skills and abilities of the team may be missing whether it's going out of house and getting vendors.
**Susan Daniels***: Or whether it's training that they may require or whether it's still going in negotiating within the company for yet another asset.
**Susan Daniels***: But it's up to you to be that go to person to keep the team humming and empowered.
**Susan Daniels***: What are the biggest challenges that project managers face is communication and making sure that the team.
**Susan Daniels***: is aware of what they need to know when they need to know it now, before we had the Internet, it was.
**Susan Daniels***: Everyone was co located and preferably in the same room well times they have changed and we have.
**Susan Daniels***: passed through that era where we had to keep everything on individual drives and our we had to print and distributed meetings, now we have sharepoint in teams and everything that we can put in the cloud all the different platforms and we can work off in the cloud.
**Susan Daniels***: The key takeaway of this slide is if you're coming to this training today and venturing into the professional project management arena understanding how to use different storage platforms is is an essential skill set it is table stakes um people if you want to list the different on.
**Susan Daniels***: file storage platforms that use and wasn't about how we keeping track of tasks that's like trial and error on Monday calm, but there's like sharepoint there's one drive.
**Susan Daniels***: box, you know where i'm going these different clouds saving platforms.
**Susan Daniels***: It is essential that you understand what they are named some of the arm the popular ones in the industry, so if you're in an interview, and they ask you are you familiar with X.
**Susan Daniels***: At least you know what kind of software program that it is, and you can say I may not have used that particular cloud file storage, but I am familiar with the concept and how to use them and they're like Okay, you know you understand cloud cloud storage and being able to share.
**Susan Daniels***: version control being familiar with how to master version control within your different software's.
**Susan Daniels***: Nice nice job on April right listing various file storage once version control you're going to want to go deep on learning the command menus.
**Susan Daniels***: command options on how to set excellent version control, one of the things that is very helpful is to set the naming convention for all of your files.
**Susan Daniels***: If you set the naming Convention from the beginning, can I have a hallelujah everybody can then find the files, but if it's left up to the teams, you know individual preferences, it can become a nightmare rapidly, I see I yes right.
**Susan Daniels***: Even if you've got a file storage central location, if you haven't taken the time to build that.
**Susan Daniels***: lexicon you know of how you're going to name your folders and then how you're going to name each file, so that they sort and drop down by name readily you're just you're going to ask for a lot of work that doesn't have to happen.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so that's kind of my lecture on that the key takeaway is the project manager, is responsible for the knowledge transfer and in between teams okay.
**Susan Daniels***: So we've spent quite a bit of time today working on on just a building our team right lot of things to take into consideration.
**Susan Daniels***: Go back through and look at those enabler slides and make sure you know what each one of those enablers are and that when you see that word you've got a concept you've got an idea of what it's referencing and why it would be important.
**Susan Daniels***: we're going to move on our next break is going to be close to 1215 okay so i'm going to change now to the next task which is defined team ground rules.
**Susan Daniels***: Here we go again with our enablers.
**Susan Daniels***: The team Charter and the team norms okay define team ground rules, these are different from your project charter Okay, you have a team Charter in a project charter.
**Susan Daniels***: And we'll see that will spend some time today talking about negotiation as well, but that'll be after break.
**Susan Daniels***: team norms okay.
**Susan Daniels***: team norms are basically, how do we play well together okay that's what it's about and it has to do with, and how are we going to set up this team, so that we can manage expectations.
**Susan Daniels***: So you create some guidelines Okay, for how frequently, are we going to me when is the best window of time if we've got people across multiple time zones.
**Susan Daniels***: One of your team norms is that all team meetings or you know where everybody has to be there on our optimum team meeting hours will be between this window of time and that okay that's probably your team norms.
**Susan Daniels***: Communication, do you have an expectation of how quickly someone gets back to you on an email I bet you mentally you have an expectation.
**Susan Daniels***: You might even have an expectation on how fast people should get back to you on a text well Maybe my idea of what's a good response time isn't even close to what you expect.
**Susan Daniels***: And suddenly there's conflict that could have been avoided if we just created a norm, that all emails will be acknowledged or responded to within.
**Susan Daniels***: One footnote within 24 hours.
**Susan Daniels***: Maybe texts need to be responded to within an hour okay or two, I mean, whatever your team wants to set up this is where you spell it out.
**Susan Daniels***: conflict management, this is where your team talks proactively about what happens if you observe conflict and there's all kinds of strategies for conflict management that will cover later, but this goes in your team charter.
**Susan Daniels***: and decision making, what kind of does everything have to go through the project manager.
**Susan Daniels***: Literally every decision or can decisions being made on certain topics, what kind of this is kind of your authority who's your go to person to get a decision made.
**Susan Daniels***: You don't want to be the keeper of all the authority you'll bottleneck your own project so in your team charter you say for this kind of thing.
**Susan Daniels***: joe's got the last decision for this kind of thing we need to have Maria she will be the decision maker and.
**Susan Daniels***: Now she may want to come back to the project manager and go, I want to bounce this off you, which is fine Okay, but your team doesn't have to wait to get on your agenda before they can move either she can handle it or she let you know, but things can keep moving.
**Susan Daniels***: Now, your team norms should align to the pmi code of ethics study this slide you need to know each of these specifically okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Now.
**Susan Daniels***: responsibility.
**Susan Daniels***: simply means you're going to do what you say you do okay and you're going to deliver, when you say you're going to deliver you don't say i'll give that to you tonight, before I leave and then not do it.
**Susan Daniels***: You can say i'll have that to you tomorrow and not do it that's not following the pmi ethics okay be good for your word.
**Susan Daniels***: Respect respect simply means treat everyone, regardless of their role in the company from clerk to senior Vice President, with this same.
**Susan Daniels***: Genuine respect and openness, you are not above anyone and you need everyone to get your project successfully executed she's so show respect to all and that gets back to that inclusiveness and that open communication.
**Susan Daniels***: Now fairness fairness is often on comes into play when there's over time and everybody wants it, you have to share it spread, you have to spread it evenly when there's over time and nobody wants it, you have to spread it evenly okay don't play favorites in any way for your fairness.
**Susan Daniels***: The next thing is honesty and you would think that would be easy to do in project management, because you're fundamentally an honest person.
**Susan Daniels***: And it should be, but the biggest challenge in honesty comes to this when you have someone underperforming.
**Susan Daniels***: And you're using red light green light yellow light status this simply says it's good to go it's in trouble it's got a serious problem that it may not hit its original budget or schedule.
**Susan Daniels***: People will not want you to put anything in red light status, and they will talk try to talk you out of it for a long time, your job is to be honest and when a part of your project is not going to hit the original.
**Susan Daniels***: baseline schedule our baseline budget, you need to let senior leadership know because what that does is two things.
**Susan Daniels***: One if they can count on you to tell them when things are going wrong, then they can trust you when thing when you tell them things are going well.
**Susan Daniels***: and trust and integrity is really your stock in trade and project management it's your reputation.
**Susan Daniels***: Secondly, when you put something in red light status it draws attention to it, which is exactly what you need, because these are the problem solvers your sponsors who have more resources and more influence than you have.
**Susan Daniels***: And they can begin to Problem Solving on your behalf and have your project you get the help that is needed to get your project back on schedule, instead of burying it and trying to play Nice and it then become unrecoverable and it starts to have a ripple effects to your project.
**Susan Daniels***: be honest call it the way it is okay, it will go a long way.
**Susan Daniels***: How is this tested, there is a code of ethics in project management, some of them are mandatory behaviors some of them are aspirational behaviors.
**Susan Daniels***: find the code of ethics and then memorize the mandatory behaviors for responsible respect fairness and honesty.
**Susan Daniels***: Many of you see a test question on these you'll know which ones are mandatory aligned to which of the values and you'll be able to roll out which ones aren't mandatory or which ones are only aspirational.
**Susan Daniels***: or whether it has to do with fairness or honesty, so you have to study the pmi code of ethics.
**Susan Daniels***: just looking at the chat for a moment.
**Susan Daniels***: So.
**Susan Daniels***: Do you agree with my perspective on honesty i'm going to throw that out there.
**Susan Daniels***: Have you been on the receiving end of needing to make that tough call from call something from red light and it's not where it needs to be.
**Susan Daniels***: it's a tough call because you're about to embarrass somebody nobody wants to be responsible for embarrassing somebody else, at least in a professional environment, maybe is a prank but not otherwise right integrity is non negotiable okay it's extremely important.
**Susan Daniels***: To be honest, in your reporting, so now that you've kind of set your norms you've kind of talked about how your team is going to work.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, I really liked the feedback i'm seeing in the chat so.
**Susan Daniels***: As you can see my voice is getting a little raspy sorry um.
**Susan Daniels***: This one is a team charter, this is an important slide as well this tells you as a Punch list what elements go in the team charter.
**Susan Daniels***: The way that you'll you may see this tested is that they are going to give you elements from this checklist and you need to identify it not as team norms, not as project charter, but as the team charter.
**Susan Daniels***: There will be lots of questions in the test question bank that have you identify what are the elements of a particular document like what goes in your resource management plan what goes in your.
**Susan Daniels***: team charter these sort of things and we'll have many of these that will cover over the coming days, but this slide you need to match these elements okay to it now the nice thing is there are templates available out in pmi.
**Susan Daniels***: And pmi standards, plus that you can start with you don't have to start with an empty blank piece of paper you can Google examples as well okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Now ground rules okay.
**Susan Daniels***: ground rules are things that are not to be violated Okay, these are i'm not just how to play nice with each other, but these are serious expectations of how this team will.
**Susan Daniels***: perform.
**Susan Daniels***: what's acceptable and what's unacceptable.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Now.
**Susan Daniels***: There can be ground rules around on when a deliverable has to be posted how to this to the site, so that everyone can look at it.
**Susan Daniels***: Before you go into your agile sprint release meeting okay or yeah agile sprint review.
**Susan Daniels***: Everyone wants to least have a chance to see what everyone's bringing to you know into the room and nobody gets to come in and walston at the 11th.
**Susan Daniels***: hour, you know later than that and just nobody's seen what they're going to present.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay that's the ground rule that's unacceptable right, you have to have your work ready for team review by X amount of time before it's due right to be move forward.
**Susan Daniels***: On ground rules can be, and I know this seems silly and petty but as we move back into the offices, how many of you have ever walked up to the copier and it's out of paper.
**Susan Daniels***: Somebody probably knew they left it without any paper ground rolls right you're in a hurry you're trying to make copies before you had to your meeting, and now you have to okay loaded with paper.
**Susan Daniels***: that's a ground rule violation you can't do the can't leave the copier brand on jammed right, and these are just little things that make the team run better.
**Susan Daniels***: Your ground rules can be response times okay.
**Susan Daniels***: And it can be hot how your how you're naming your files there's just a variety of things, the difference between a normal ground rule is this.
**Susan Daniels***: A norm is kind of what I can expect, but if you don't do it there's really no consequences to me too much or to anybody else is just kind of a way we want, we will.
**Susan Daniels***: We will interact with.
**Susan Daniels***: Like the arm the norm might be that the teams team meetings start exactly on time right that's the norm.
**Susan Daniels***: The ground rule might be you can't be more than five minutes late to a meeting period, you get a reputation of being more than five minutes late to a meeting you've broken ground rule now we're gonna you know, have a little powwow about that okay so it's really where you want to implement.
**Susan Daniels***: consequences, am I, making sense here okay norms equals values in many ways that's true that's a question in the chat um we will treat each other with respect, we will not interrupt each other, we will um.
**Susan Daniels***: Those are our values are that we're going to be honest with each other, we are going to be on play fair, we are going to share these like you said norms can be closer to values ground rules are very close to behaviors that have consequences of their not met.
**Susan Daniels***: I like late equals, bringing the donuts yeah if you're late chances are you got doing everything you can just to get there, but I can definitely see where they're they're responsible for next meetings donuts okay our norms and ground rules part of the team charter, yes, yes, they are.
**Susan Daniels***: um I see ground rules are the pillars on which this team will stand exactly swear jar absolutely.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm swear jar is basically on, you have to pay for every swear word that you use, it is highly effective, by the way, and all that money from this word jar was put into the party after the project.
**Susan Daniels***: Now I need to move on and talk about negotiation skills, because that's really what it's going to take.
**Susan Daniels***: To on to be successful in building your team acquiring it from the different sources that you may need to go to negotiating the rate setting up the organization.
**Susan Daniels***: delegating the authorities and the decision making process that's all negotiating okay you're going to need to negotiate how you're going to manage conflict which we'll talk about shortly, but negotiation is an essential essential Scott skill set of a project manager.
**Susan Daniels***: It really arm.
**Susan Daniels***: it's part of your your go to is what you do almost all day long you're negotiating solutions and negotiating schedule adjustments or can I get part of it by this date, how much can I get right and then go shooting rates for years for your talent that you get in.
**Susan Daniels***: um can the team can you guys put in chat illustrations of how you've needed to negotiate when you're in your projects.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm it's listing roles and responsibilities priorities you know assignments who's going to get it who's not but i'm.
**Susan Daniels***: timeliness right what is going to be considered timeliness almost right almost always beating the clock right we're always trying to negotiate the clock people want more time we don't have that time to give them, so how much can you give me right, and when will you have it by.
**Susan Daniels***: Expectations of resources right you hear your team May.
**Susan Daniels***: have high expectations and you've got to negotiate those resources.
**Susan Daniels***: Getting.
**Susan Daniels***: Negotiating funding exactly.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay i'm negotiating schedules right for your individual staff it's it's all day every day we're negotiating so let's look at.
**Susan Daniels***: You know negotiating a variety of things you're negotiating internally and externally within your company.
**Susan Daniels***: Because you may need vendors, or you may you to get your job done and you'll be negotiating with them, but perhaps with the assistance of the procurement team, but still you're going to be negotiating.
**Susan Daniels***: um you're going to need to negotiate service level agreements between divisions right when can you have this ready for handoff right and what is the quality expectations for that deliverable for the next handoff you know be negotiating i'm.
**Susan Daniels***: Just it's nonstop inside and outside.
**Susan Daniels***: Excuse me.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm just gonna take a look ahead for a moment.
**Susan Daniels***: Ah, OK so let's say that you come to an impasse right.
**Susan Daniels***: and
**Susan Daniels***: there's conflict right, so now we need to talk about how do we deal with conflict conflict management well we're not talking about that right, this minute, but conflict management in negotiation or flip sides of the same coin right conflict is when.
**Susan Daniels***: Things are not reaching agreement negotiation is when you're actually pursuing agreement and the only way out of conflict is often through negotiating between the parties.
**Susan Daniels***: No i'm one of the things that you need to be very sensitive to is that you can't ignore conflict.
**Susan Daniels***: Another way of saying it I can't ignore who's.
**Susan Daniels***: Acting passive aggressive to other TEAM members, I can see it, and then you know, maybe I can't deal with it right, this minute because i've got another commitment for the next hour, but don't let it slide on addressed okay.
**Susan Daniels***: You simply need to first thing is i've noticed, there seems to be a conflict between you two I don't know what it is and unless you need me to resolve it i'm not getting involved.
**Susan Daniels***: But I want you to know it's visible now can you to need to work it out let's take you know let's find a time when you too can have a private room and you can work through this.
**Susan Daniels***: Do you think you can handle it yourselves, or what do you need a meeting and most times are too embarrassed and they'll say they can try to mediate it themselves, most of the time, but you let them know you see it it's a problem and needs to be addressed okay.
**Susan Daniels***: One of the team norms or one of the ground words, depending on how you want to set it up is that um conflict and within the team will not go on resolved and get you just can't let it.
**Susan Daniels***: Go on, resolved, because it really does create destructive behavior it creates poor performance it be creates.
**Susan Daniels***: Just sabotage if you let it go on too long anybody ever been on the receiving end to sabotage within their work environment.
**Susan Daniels***: People sabotaging each other, unfortunately i'm seeing yeses right that's your leaders fault okay that's leadership for not addressing obvious you know conspicuous conflict, it needs to be addressed.
**Susan Daniels***: yeah not addressing conflict will create a new norm ronnie you nailed it really um so as the project manager you've got to you've got to build that in that you're going to address it, and they need to be it's not going to go unresolved.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay here is our first got set of guidelines you're going to see many slides like this okay they're going to have the same structure they're going to be found out of your elbow choice on location, I said it's under checklist.
**Susan Daniels***: These are the things that, step by step, you do when you have to rectify violations and ground rules.
**Susan Daniels***: i'll give you a moment to read it.
**Susan Daniels***: Now, their words you you address it Okay, and you may need to remove and replace the offending team Member.
**Susan Daniels***: And they need to know that that needs to be in part of the team charter right the conflict will not go on unresolved and if conflict cannot be resolved.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay mediation will be pursued right with to appear or the project manager failing that i'm team Member assign TEAM members may be reassigned.
**Susan Daniels***: um.
**Susan Daniels***: I want you to arm to put in your notes I don't know if you've got these slides yet, but this is these again, I cannot stress this enough, this is one of these these slides all of your guidelines are key sources of exam questions.
**Susan Daniels***: Well, I have reached the next point and I, this is a good breaking point so we're going to go set up for the next break and when we come back we'll walk we'll start with a video on negotiating project agreements so i'm give me a minute to set up the clock and i'll See you in about 15.
**Susan Daniels***: start.